I've been doing high dose IV vitamin C treatments, but I feel I need to take a break as my veins are harder to access.
I read that the supplement of a lestin, which is a brand of extensive, can be equivalent to the IVs. Are you familiar with this? Yes, I am familiar with that.
I have one other person right now that I know of that is taking that that he has a basal cell carcinoma.
But he's taking the topical form of that and he feels like he's it's helping the last time I talked to him.
He's had a switch to a lot of different topical forms, different supplements because something will work for a period of time and it stops working any switches right now.
He's on that and he's thinking that it's helpful.
So how helpful do you think IV vitamin C is for treating or battling cancer?
I think it can be very helpful, but so can everything right. So certainly if you feel like you need to take a break, just like any supplement protocol you're on, taking a break from something is really affordable, pulsing it.
It doesn't mean that you won't go back to it at some point in time, but taking a break for three or four months can be beneficial to help.
It can also be beneficial so that your body doesn't get used to that and then it has no benefits. So there can, you know, we have other benefits other than just giving your veins a rest to take it a break for something.
You're also this person who's asking this question is doing a lot of other things. So you can't possibly do everything out there. It would not be good for you to do everything out there.
It would overwhelm your liver. It would kill you if you did everything out there. So you, there's nothing wrong with, you know, praying about your decision making process and making the decision to stop doing something for a short period of time.
Forever, but there's nothing wrong with stopping.